etiopía tiene un problema de imagen
durante años este gigantesco país es el
segundo más poblado de todo áfrica con
casi 100 millones de habitantes fue
sinónimo de pobreza extrema hambre
enfermedades guerras definitiva de
auténtica miseria
[Música]
sin embargo amigos con el nuevo siglo
todo empezó a cambiar aunque etiopía
sigue siendo un país muy pobre durante
la última década este país se ha
convertido en una de las economías de
mayor crecimiento no solo de áfrica sino
de todo el planeta al mismo tiempo se ha
convertido en un país muy cercano a
pekín y también en un estrecho aliado de
eeuu en la lucha contra el terrorismo
porque tener una sola amistad si puedes
tener las dos el caso es que es muy
probable amigos que estemos presenciando
ni más ni menos que el nacimiento de
toda una futura potencia africana
y ese es un motivo más que suficiente
para que aquí en visual político no
queremos perdernos que está ocurriendo
en un país al que ya muchos comienzan a
denominar como la nueva china africana
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tras décadas de tensión hostilidad y
enfrentamiento antes y después de que
eritrea se independizara de etiopía en
1993 este pasado 9 de julio de 2018
ambos países sellaron la paz
y ojo porque durante todo el largo
tiempo que duró el enfrentamiento entre
etiopía y eritrea se vivieron momentos
de acontecimientos tan trágicos como el
conflicto militar que entre 1998 y el
año 2000 se llevó la vida de casi
100.000 personas ahora en cambio los
líderes de los dos países han acordado
firmar una paz completa
hemos acordado reanudar los servicios de
nuestras compañías aéreas conseguir que
nuestros puertos funcionen hacer que
nuestra gente comercio y abrir nuestras
embajadas de nuevo ya no hay fronteras
entre eritrea y etiopía porque un puente
de amor la ha destruido había hammett
primer ministro de etiopía pero claro la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es que ha
cambiado para que ahora de repente estos
dos países se quieran tanto pues amigos
aunque pueda parecer increíble uno de
los problemas que ha impedido la
reconciliación ha sido está al día que
veis en la imagen but me un lugar donde
no hay prácticamente nada de nada
y
y es que veréis conforme a los acuerdos
de paz que se negociaron en argel en el
año 2000 para poner fin a la última
guerra este territorio le corresponde le
pertenece a eritrea pero digamos que el
gobierno etíope al final se dio cuenta
de que no estaba por la labor así que
las cosas se quedaron encalladas hasta
este preciso momento ahora etiopía el
país con diferencia más fuerte de los
dos al fin y al cabo hablamos de 100
millones frente a poco más de 5 ha
decidido ceder
y es que amigos en muchas ocasiones eso
de empecinarse con ganar por ser el más
fuerte es un error a veces este tipo de
conflictos son malos para todos no hay
nada que ganar y si mucho que perder en
cualquier caso esta paz es un buen
reflejo de los cambios que se están
produciendo atentos porque puede que os
llevéis alguna sorpresa
un modelo a la china
en los últimos años etiopía se ha
convertido en una de las economías con
mayor crecimiento de todo el planeta
[Música]
durante la última década de etiopía ha
promediado un crecimiento medio de
alrededor del 10 del 10 por ciento cada
año
atentos por ejemplo al siguiente gráfico
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí podemos comparar el crecimiento del
pib per cápita de etiopía con el de otro
de los países que más está creciendo del
mundo
vietnam y ojo porque el crecimiento de
la población de etiopía es enorme y aquí
hablamos del pib per cápita pero un
momento no se trata solo de la economía
como os podéis imaginar todo este
crecimiento ha tenido también
importantes consecuencias sociales que
es algo que tarde o temprano siempre
ocurre cuando un país crece se abre al
mundo y hace bien las cosas
desde el año 2000 la esperanza media de
vida ha crecido en 13 años el número de
trabajadores con al menos la educación
secundaria completada ha crecido casi un
50% y la pobreza bueno fijaos qué está
ocurriendo con la pobreza
[Música]
y lo sabemos aún hoy hay muchísima
pobreza en etiopía con una simple
búsqueda en google podremos encontrar
situaciones terribles en este país pero
es que amigos hablemos claro superar la
pobreza no es algo que suceda de la
noche a la mañana ojalá fuera tan fácil
[Música]
addis abeba la capital del país es un
buen reflejo del proceso que está
experimentando etiopía las grúas las
obras y los proyectos de todo tipo
inundan la ciudad de hecho fue aquí en
esta ciudad donde en 2015 se inauguró el
primer metro ligero de toda el áfrica
sub-sahariana
pero claro llegados a este punto la
pregunta a la que nos enfrentamos es
clarísima cómo diantres etiopía ha
logrado semejante salto económico pues
amigos podemos decir que este país se ha
convertido en algo así como el alumno
aventajado de pekín
por así decirlo la apuesta de
crecimiento ha tratado de copiar en gran
medida a la del gigante asiático fijaos
por un lado el gobierno de etiopía ha
impulsado la construcción de gigantescas
infraestructuras imprescindibles para el
desarrollo del país
hablamos por ejemplo de la línea de
ferrocarril de más de 4 mil millones de
dólares que conecta a addis abeba con el
puerto de yibutí para facilitar la
exportación de mercancías o de la mayor
obra de toda áfrica
la presa del renacimiento una gigantesca
presa en el río nilo cuya inversión se
acerca ojo a los 6.000 millones de
dólares y que tiene como misión
revolucionar el sistema energético del
país con electricidad abundante y barata
por cierto sabéis quién ha puesto la
pasta y el conocimiento para estos
proyectos pues seguro que a los que
seguís habitualmente visual política no
os sorprende en gran medida ha sido
china las empresas chinas
[Música]
de hecho china se ha convertido en el
mayor inversor y también en el mayor
socio comercial de etiopía es decir gran
parte de todo el crecimiento que el país
ha tenido se ha producido gracias a sus
lazos con chinos
segundo pilar poco a poco las grandes
empresas públicas comenzaron a operar
con bastante autonomía y a gestionarse
como si fueran empresas privadas
[Música]
este es el caso por ejemplo de pian
airlines la aerolínea de bandera del
país que se ha convertido en la mayor
aerolínea africana y que ahora se
propone competir a nivel internacional
con las grandes del sector
[Música]
a pesar de que se obvian airlines es
100% de propiedad del estado se dirige
como un negocio privado la junta dirige
la empresa como si se tratara de british
airways y united airlines cmd n
mega tu presidente de fairfax áfrica
fund y por último el tercer pilar la
atracción de inversión extranjera
directa mediante el desarrollo de zonas
económicas e incentivos fiscales
financiación participativa etcétera
etcétera fijaos cómo han evolucionado
las inversiones extranjeras de esta
forma es como etiopía ha comenzado a
industrializarse en gran medida por
todas estas políticas y también por el
coste de la mano de obra una industria
por ejemplo que ha crecido mucho en los
últimos años ha sido la textil de hecho
marcas como h&m guess o calvin klein ya
producen algunas de sus prendas en este
país sin embargo desafortunadamente aquí
no termina todo las similitudes con
china no se limitan sólo a la parte
económica
al mismo tiempo que el país ha vivido
todo un despegue económico la represión
de las libertades civiles se hizo cada
vez más y más fuerte se cerraron medios
de comunicación se persiguió la
oposición política se bloquearon páginas
web etcétera etcétera
durante los últimos años este país se
convirtió en uno de los diez mayores
carceleros de periodistas de todo el
mundo prácticamente el gobierno de
etiopía en ferro forzó al exilio o
intimidó a casi todos los periodistas
independientes
'vamos en otras palabras que
prácticamente se llegó a una situación
en la que en etiopía no había
periodistas sino portavoces del gobierno
pero amigos he esperado un momento
porque ahora de repente parece que todo
ha empezado a cambiar atentos
[Música]
una nueva generación
a principios de 2018 etiopía estaba
sumida en una ola de violencia
enfrentamientos raciales y una represión
política durísima hacían que la
estabilidad del país pareciera a punto
de venirse abajo
además aunque económicamente las cosas
han funcionado bastante bien en los
últimos años también se han producido
algunos desequilibrios una deuda
extranjera no precisamente pequeña una
gran escasez de divisas como
consecuencia de las grandes inversiones
y como la población crece muchísimo un
desempleo juvenil bastante pero que
bastante alto
vamos que muchos se preguntaban si lo
vivido por etiopía en los últimos años
no había sido más que un espejismo sin
embargo contra todo pronóstico tras una
dura lucha de poder el partido
gobernante el frente democrático
revolucionario del pueblo etíope en la
práctica el partido único eligió como
primer ministro a había cnet un ex
oficial del ejército de 42 años no se
esperaba nada pero en tan sólo unos
meses boom como han cambiado las cosas
fijaos desde que llegó al poder había me
ha puesto en libertad a muchos presos
políticos ha pedido disculpas por los
abusos del gobierno ha denunciado a
altos cargos de los servicios de
inteligencia y de las fuerzas de
seguridad por haber cometido terrorismo
de estado' ha impulsado el acuerdo de
paz con eritrea ha anunciado una
modificación de la constitución para
establecer la limitación de mandatos ya
ha comenzado a desmontar la censura
política y a pedir a los periodistas
exiliados que regresen a casa etiopía
desbloquea 264 páginas web y canales de
televisión y no sólo eso también ha
anunciado que el gobierno va a
profundizar en la liberalización de la
economía para atraer más inversiones al
país
etiopía abre la puerta del mundo con un
plan de privatización sin precedentes
claro que como os podéis imaginar tantos
cambios no han sentado nada bien a
muchos miembros de la élite del país y
la respuesta no se hizo esperar
un muerto y 156 heridos en el atentado
contra un acto del primer ministro de
etiopía el pasado 23 de junio de 2018
durante un acto político en el corazón
de addis abeba en el que el presidente
vestía una camiseta de nelson mandela
hubo quien trató de poner fin a esta
especie de transición política sin
embargo fallaron y ahora el primer
ministro parece tener muy claro que
tiene que pisar el acelerador
[Música]
etiopía amigos sigue siendo un país muy
pobre con muchos pero que muchos
problemas políticos sociales y
económicos sin embargo el que un día de
no hace mucho tiempo fue considerado el
país más miserable de la tierra hoy
parece tener una oportunidad para
despegar lo conseguirá sólo el tiempo
podrá contestar a esta pregunta desde
luego aquí en visual política estaremos
muy atentos a los acontecimientos si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
te invitamos a darle al botón de like y
no olvides suscribirte a visual polític
para estar al tanto de nuestras
novedades un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]